في المقابل قالت مديرته الاستخبارات
الوطنيه الامريكيه افريل هاينز انها تتوقع
ان يستمر القتال في التباطؤ في اوكرانيا
خلال الاشهر القادمه
ان الولايات المتحده لم ترى ما يفيد
بتقديم الصين المساعده العسكريه لروسيا
لان الصينيين يواصلون العمل مع روسيا على
مجموعه متنوعه من الاشياء والسعي لدعم
موسكو في المنتديات الدوليه حسب قولها
الصين على مجموعه متنوعه من الاشياء
يواصلون على اجتماعات والسعيدي لايجاد طرق
لدعم موسكو في المنتديات الدوليه
لمساعدتهم على اداره الجهود لفضحي او
ادانه ما يفعله الروس الصينيون يقدمون
اشكال مختلفه من المساعده لا نرى اي شيء
يفيد بتعليم المساعده العسكريه لكن هناك
اشياء اخرى تقنعنا ونستمر في مراقبه الوضع